I'm braced to robots hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to the
mega episode of five nights at Freddy's
fan games now you may think that I've
played a lot of five nights at Freddy's
fan games in my career but to be
perfectly honest I haven't even
scratched the surface as you can see
this is page one of almost 5,000 games
so five nights at Freddy's fan game
world is ludicrously big but I'm here to
give you Valley I've picked out five
different five nights at Freddy's good
every time I squid every time there is
Nerdist news I got it Aaron my boy and
I'm doing this because I care because I
don't want to waste your time because I
want to treat you to something special I
want to improve what a let's play is and
this time you get a buffet
all-you-can-eat of the various different
five nights at Freddy's fan games so
without further ado let's get started
now I played the final nights three demo
as far as I remember so this is this is
a
yeah that's good stuff hey oh okay all
right I'm gonna get going
see you in the game buddies that's
creepy don't look at me like that
the mystery of Fred berries is a very
interesting one uh-huh that much seems
to be known but I think I got a good
lead so far a couple of days ago it said
something in the mail I was told was
inside may be of interest to me
mm-hm finally after sorting out all the
rest of the junk mail I got uh open this
one my pleasure
saw some very intriguing things inside
on the outside was a note that said this
once belong to my grandfather who worked
at fredbear's he disappeared soon after
and this is all that was left of him new
information is always great and it's
even better with a story attached I
Robot inside the letter into my
amazement I found a key to the entrance
of Fred berry simle diner another thing
and that the person's grandfather may
have worked here as a night guard or
something about the chip attempts at the
key as of right now I am pending on
visiting the old establishment soon and
see what I can do with what was sent to
me if anyone has any close to this
grandfather character is leave her
applied below I really am interested in
knowing who this person is really max
Donovan paranormal investigator all
right well you're gonna die I know that
for a investigation these are so well
made that's the thing about like all
these where it all started he says
they're so well made that's the son
that's such an impressive thing about it
like they're honestly well made there's
a lot of love that's been put into these
look at this [ __ ] nope I gotta back that
won't work I didn't try anything nope
that won't work okay
alright whatever you say I am outie okay
but there's so much like love put into
these games it's shocking
alright let's go in here choose the keys
I guess oh yeah that's really cool I
didn't read that where am I
Who am I why are you who's there hello
okay what did you get for me well that's
a comforting sound okay dive headfirst
into the fan okay that's an option
what is the growling huh
why explain to me what the growling is
oh right okay all right good I know what
you want but I'll wander around this
place where whoa I see someone's doing
kungfu back there wait a minute is that
just is that just the dust cloud or am I
seeing something gone witty woody in the
back
coulda sworn I saw someone going we'll
buddy whoo buddy
all right go forward [ __ ] steam god
dammit you Sackett it's you Sokka Jets
oh you're a big bunch of ass
alright fine then got blasted in the ass
with steam I don't think that Keys go
that won't work
shocking I know who'da thought it would
work and this is cool okay maybe this
this is legitimately cool this is really
cool huh heard the thumpy try this here
I don't know what this is
it worked perfectly done oh oh oh it's a
flashlight
well I got myself a key and now I am
going to use it here
it's so awesome it's like a
point-and-click adventure game it's so
cool you don't need to be so thumpy you
door oh there we go the comforting
noises of madness alright hello how
about a flashlight - uncle
that won't work alright that won't work
that oh right I think I fixed it not a
hundred percent sure but I think I fixed
it
alright let's go down look I did see
something going wiggle wobble in the
high alright I guess this is normal ah
yes I love this it's my favorite show
hello Oh
Oh is my favorite show oh okay
why hi hello hi for what am i doing and
why I don't I don't fully understand
what I'm doing the air okay
nothing just fiddle diddling with my
flashlight I have no idea what it was
what am I hello hello how are you doing
welcome to
what what what what could you possibly
want it from me who is the point of that
I'm a paranormal investigator I don't
watch a puppet show okay so the answer
is got a flashing what hey don't get it
that's law yes this I don't get it I
just don't get it
have a good day it's like a live ICU
hello okay so I'm supposed to peekaboo
the puppets but not the puppet the
puppet sir but not the puppet all right
thank you I don't know this is a good
show great show I got nothing else to
say besides how good the show is it's
really good love it even all right well
you keep beaker booing me I ain't gonna
change I'm just as handsome as I was
before
you can't peek-a-boo I see you
okay all right oh I'm fine my name is
markiplier okay all right hi hello my
name is markiplier I'm I make videos on
the internet I have a funny feeling I'm
doing well but I don't know
okay well then thank you though
all right we did it all right good job
everybody
[Music]
function first up you have your cameras
up front
activate that my personal space on the
keyboard in front of you you can press s
to exit back out didn't took the liberty
of going to some state of the art set
for us here they're just doing that
could detect your fingers locations with
visible lasers
pretty fancy stuff anyway to switch
canvas now you also have your alarm and
air refresh buttons for now we go along
maybe be a la pressing it will signal up
right loud and red alarm to ring in
whatever room you have selected on the
camera you can ring the alarm near your
office by English it
and now I'll tear out of a tronic
buddies courtesy of me of course bears
up first taking the role of power
basically try and find guests or staff
members now all you have to do is you go
under any noise
so whenever he's taking a break to take
any sounds or sing
try bringing the alarms at nearby rooms
leading them told you a couple of times
once it's close enough say one alarm and
near your office that's a shift key
remember Bobby however is a bit of a
different beast you'll wander around
looking for intruders normally if you
wear your guard uniform your me and chip
inside did not register you as an
intruder however you exactly fit the
last guards uniforms so until you can
tailor yourself a new one just try to
avoid any contact with him but if he
does manage it into your office
try and stay completely still
one of his parameters for checking if
someone's human is if it moves thusly to
stay completely still okay I don't
understand any of it or why why do I
need to bring them to me why do I need
to bring them to me I'd done it who is
there how's that poster
I don't know what's happening hi I'm
very confused sir get up
call 9-1-1 hello
can you help you wait can't do that I
have no idea what I'm doing
I'd literally have no idea whoa I can
move I can move all right even if that's
not good hey oh that's weird
oh oh they're moving I don't know what
that means fire in the kitchen hello
okay all right well I might be both I
might be I might be expressly completely
boned oh hello hi
hello hi oh that's weird
I'm not the free-roam you guys are the
free roam that's real good real good
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's problem that's a big problem
that's Bradham I'm a funcle' solution
isn't a fake except no straight
[Applause]
and all right well see ya I'm braced I'm
so damn damn son where'd you get that
but anyway that is all the time I have
for a 5-minute final nights for I gotta
move on to the next game here boy
yes he was about right oh it's all-star
votes are coming fed to the rules and I
hit the ground running done magnetized
not all there forth what day shift at
Freddy's one ending will you continue
from what I had no idea what this game
was so I have no idea I'm just gonna
pick random I would like najran oh so P
sounds real good man I should have
played DSA f1 I guess but not too late
Oh No welcome to the new and improved
Freddy's thank you for responding most
people don't want to work here after
what happened to the old location are
the rumors true I don't know what rumors
but are the rumors true no nothing could
be further from the truth
fredbear wasn't even in Reno on June
24th that is propaganda spread by those
candies burgers and chips oh wait did
you mean the last location oh yeah I
guess so essentially we're hiring you
here to work the day shift you'll be
wearing mascot suits delivering pizza
cleaning up messes all that kind of
stuff
you ever work in one of those joins
before I worked in Colorado I worked in
Fred why this is really in-depth I am
out of my element all right I worked at
the sister location filled with dago's
that sounds like me I'm terribly
sorry I don't know what the company was
thinking that that time let's we'll put
only random dog O's in a location all it
was for one dog Oh to start barking we
had to ship the leftover dago's do as
many locations as possible meaning we
can't have random dago's roaming with
most locations you seem to know what
you're doing our grand reopening is
tomorrow you know today is a trial day
of sorts to make sure the robots working
most of them don't catch fire the
transit rash file the trash pile may
combust so would you like a small tour
so you can see what you got around the
day shift ah just a short tour all right
sure thing I'll show you the most vital
stops now let us depart welcome to the
show stage is one of the areas where you
can perform with a brand-new robots
oh that chicken looks oddly promiscuous
don't wanna say nothing about that
chicken bye dad
yeah if you asked me the company is
asking for troubles giving a robot those
hips
imagine if foxy had hips like that I
don't want to imagine that I don't want
to imagine that at all actually I don't
want to even closely imagine that this
is the prize corner our groovy clerk
Matt will exchange all tokens you give
him for cool prizes and that ain't
another thing you've got blue here's
wind-up a music box over in the prize
corner that way that white circle on the
top left of your screen indicates how
urgent it is that you want up the box if
you let it wind all the way down it
comes out oh whoa what is it well that
doesn't matter alright
all that matters is that you don't let
the box wine all the way down please for
everyone's sake
alright what is that noise that's the
mangle basically too many people who
gift the Deku Fox so we made it less
sexy but someone keeps tearing it apart
I'm pretty sure it's Dave I'm too lazy
to put it back together in the company
can't afford a technician we spent all
over moolah building these terrible
plastic abominations so we sort of just
use it as a take apart put back together
attraction it's easier than actually
trying to talk to Dave believe me it's
easier was Dave the purple guy wait the
restrooms have cameras in them that's we
got to put him in there ever since what
happened in Seattle seriously who knew
that Freddy could do so much damage with
urinal and a blowtorch I don't want to
know that story I really got it
now that we're in the office we can
start our job interview so what's your
name all right oh oh ah okay
sure my name is my name is four three
three
my name is shrimp shrimp old frame
Bolton I'm sorry mister well my name I
mean who is free ball to that it lets me
knowing I remember that name from
Colorado fast crime and related activity
we're both aware of what I did
we are both aware of what I did with oxy
oh yeah
look the plastics is the past is the
past is the past
but frankly the newer plastic models
might be too fragile for that especially
the trash pile
they are literally they're literally
made of dildo material though yeah I
told them making robotics out of plastic
and latex was a crummy idea do you have
any medical issues we should know about
I be there's blood sometimes I carve out
battle pieces I have the gown I'm
sexually attracted to robots look just
keep your Shmack and no one keeps free
bulton smacking wepper and free pull
Tim's briefs no one and yet what yo
seems yourens acceptable medical
condition now since you've worked for
Freddy's you've already signed our
contract no need to sign it again pal we
own you wait what alright whatever you
say save game sure all right I saved it
I'm so happy ha ha ha alright
Oh
hello why are you here interact with
mangle
pick flesh okay all right well all right
no no you found no I don't like that no
don't like that as much but repair you
Oh
oh we've got one BOTS mangle you botched
that up in all seriousness it looks even
worse let's try to repair it again come
on let's give this another go if at
first you don't succeed get back on that
horse
oh don't I'm not done yet man let me
give another crack at this I just gotta
get some elbow grease in there
I gotta get your elbows all greased up
oh [ __ ] that doesn't go there what are
you doing get out [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right well I guess we'll just have
to try that again
god this is ridiculous this is ludicrous
I love it I'm gonna make balloon animals
all right okay time to inflate some
balloons penis like oh just gonna always
go back away from this one and see why I
guess I'm out of here okay whatever you
say I need oh ah let's interact with
balloon boy god I'm gonna throw you at a
wall well I'm sorry
employee what have you done why did you
do this I'd expect this sort of behavior
from Dave but from you now we no longer
have a balloon boy what stopping the
kids from all ganging up on toy Freddy
and kick in the shins in tell you
ripping rest no gotta wait for this to
finish I gotta get my suit on don't I
don't I have to get my suit on isn't
that a thing I have to do
hi I am NOT going to kick you say I
don't want to know what foxy gif gift F
is I'm gonna play that I'm not Pratt
this isn't my proudest
[Music]
I'm okay seriously what in the actual
[ __ ] shoo
we're golden heady as we're golden
and scare children ah excellent time to
find some kids to scare the [ __ ] out of
hello oh [ __ ] what up children sorry
ye be honest with me did you put on the
floating at Barratt just to scare small
children I'm gonna do get out this top
no more Golden Bear scrotum I don't know
what that means
I really don't understand what that
means I guess alright well if I don't
gain your scrotum I guess answer
don't get no more scrotum hello you are
doing great you are long mr. orange man
I needed that oh wow alright ok bye
who was your question would you like to
know my I am NOT your child and you are
not my papa or you have to clear nobody
likes the plastic bare plastic hmm
those two traits make me worse than
Balloon Boy and fredbear who each only
have one of those two qualities ok what
is suffering you feel like the only
thing that I know anymore ok alright you
go be an all-star
you may die now see ya alright toy chica
goddamn those hips devour devour chicas
oven-baked avian bhai okay alright well
that's weird I don't know what that
means is that a euphemism for something
I'm just gonna leave now all right see
you around
what's in the back room Wow foxy nice
dick
I guess that's that's not right I don't
wanna give the Fox repair foxy even you
can't repair a broken heart well
[Music]
what was that again the [ __ ] fog I
don't want to that's I don't wanna yar
our hair oh my gift the Fox I guess I'm
still not showing this oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah martyr father oh yeah
oh yes spank me harder daddy oh yes I
may have you the Fox get out completely
fair that is a hundred percent fair that
is fair you are fair and just I don't
feel good about myself no I don't I
don't feel good about myself no oddly
enough no I think you're a I think your
summary reason of my existence is
absolutely correct if I if I had to
imagine what would be written on my
gravestone it would be you sick [ __ ] so
I think I'm gonna leave this one there
and that is
god it's like five nights of fuckboys
really is
anyway that is day shift at Freddy's and
that is only Game two of this adventure
so uh-huh oh very nice okay
[Music]
oh okay I didn't know what I was looking
at it was purple guys sitting at a table
whoa hi welcome to the party okay all
right well I guess that's just it
all right let's get into this are you
sure new game fairly sure this is weird
this is so stylized I don't know what's
happening is that a dumpster is that a
back alley somewhere is that important
there seems to be some purple pants and
shoes hanging out of a dumpster
not a very elegant way of hiding a body
but you did your best I suppose 12
nights earlier 12 Oh II okay alright I
don't understand
hello hello hello alright control in
front of the computer
it's worth a try so your name's Chuck
Sean Sean I think it's done well my name
is Peter and I'm a former night guard is
pretty fast very soon as far as I know
you've never met me well you're just as
deep and this is me every survivor I can
find can help us to get out of here but
I try to keep you alive John I can't
protect you by my house music what
information on what to do when they wake
up and by they I'm talking about your
your childhood friends now before you
start questioning me how you could meet
them after they were killed back in the
eighties there's a pretty simple answer
you're dead John no I'm not Jim I'm
unsure of how you died but I know that
you definitely made a mistake by doing
so I think I should probably explain
myself here so so let me hurry up you
might have already noticed that this
place probably looks familiar to you
this is Fred there's family diner kind
of to be exact
it's an eternal purgatory your memory
shaped the place so for you it probably
looks like a mix of wherever you last
worked or lived in Fred there's on that
you're pretty well you could have gotten
a much worse look for this place in your
head but that's true you don't know we
do need to know is that this eternal
purgatory could potentially be escaped
from and then I have a plan how to do so
however assist me on this it's not quite
ready I'll explain it to you tomorrow
but for now it's an important step for
you to look onto the office table it's a
fan that is located next to you and get
the audio tape that is in there out of
it you will need this if you want to
escape from here
however it appears that we are really
running short on time and I should
really hurry to explain what to do
against your friends if any of your
friends come to your Security office
you're gonna experience them from a more
hostile side see I currently don't know
what exactly what happened to them
but I know something really weird must
have happened to their spirits
they're pretty messed up and broken then
I don't think they're very mentally
stable see what I noticed when
encountering them earlier when I was
still the only normal person here was
that upon putting their side on me the
only way to make them wander off is to
hide from them now the only way to
really hide from them in your case
probably is just getting out of sight
from the door through here so did you
see anybody in them run somewhere that
as far away from the doors as possible I
don't think anyone's active tonight but
I could be wrong there's this really
weird daily cycle of activity so I'm
going after that I might have forgotten
it wrong close so don't rely on too much
on me and I think that's everything for
now I am not entirely sure if your
friends will be hostile towards you but
I can't throw the idea out
I don't think they'll be able to
remember you at all really all the
earlier one is dammit I need to go right
now or Orleans gonna fine I'll get back
to you later okay
alright I don't understand anything
that's happening here I am 100% lost and
I just don't know and I don't know and
what was on the table
what were you - I collected the table
okay all right that doesn't sound good
why oh okay
alrighty then I don't understand what's
happening hmm alright even this is weird
I'm dead I'm dead I'm why's that
there's nothing hi Fred mango mango
Freddie oh okay all right I don't
understand anything about that but I'm
dead okay I'm dead and this is purgatory
this bullet oh I saw that hello friend
ooh okay all right well alright then I
am fine thing it's fine okay alright I
good that's good oh boy
I don't like any of this I could have
sworn that I saw it I'm not no that's
not what I wanted oh no oh okay hey hey
hey hey watch your moving around heavy
metal for you doing something too foxy
over there huh you doing some you
shouldn't be doing yeah my purgatory
that's not good so what's the point
rubble but you know what oh no that's I
saw you on the thing like that so what's
the point of looking at the cameras
there's no one they're after me
no no no no that's not what that's not
what it hey that's not what I wanted oh
oh okay alright I'm not gonna complain
about it yeah oh you've unlocked
characters I don't know what characters
mean but I've unlocked it no see this is
really well done I got to admit this is
really well done this is pretty pretty
impressive dragging the window might be
quicker than clicking the small right
I'm hoping the reason these spirits want
to kill you it's because they need
what's inside my theory on why these
girls turned to animatronics and that's
someone something made an attempt of
manifesting them into physical bodies
out of thin air it sounds impossible all
right yeah that's the thing whoever made
the addition failed I was likely
horribly that's why all these characters
look so weird and broken so in order to
fix themselves they possibly need a way
bigger plasma source and I think that's
where you come you're an unarmed adult
ghost which makes you a potential meal
for them they don't see us as humans
John they only see us as a chance for
survival can we really blame them for it
question leaving a message not actually
talking to you get yourself together bro
well moving on I think only one
character is gonna become active tonight
and that is the bear character I cannot
identify I have no idea what exactly he
is but it appears as a manifestation was
somewhat fruitful he seems to be
glitching and out of existence which is
why he dubbed him am i real clever right
yeah you really need to keep an eye on
that guy though or else you're gonna run
into massive problems if he's fixed and
clean here absolutely fun if he's broken
on the other hand watch him for a few
seconds you should turn back to normal
if you don't keep him normal he's gonna
really hurt you now remember that plan I
mentioned yeah you do this place is a
still a work in progress and I don't
have everything ready yet however I'm
pretty sure that there's more audiotapes
like the one you hopefully you picked up
from the reporter yesterday mm-hmm and
they're going to appear in a different
camera every night if you see it click
on it with that mountain the old
computer in your room and you'll
probably obtain it now I'm leaving it up
to you don't waste too much time
listening to this he might already be
active he hi body ok bye Bonnie oh
excuse me
alright so I need to look in the in the
in the computer monitors for these
things I need to look in the computer
monitors is that what you're saying
so how how does that work exactly how
does that work
hi joy joy joy joy joy joy did you say
your or your your here I don't know what
you I means you are why me no I know
what your homie no means I don't know
what your means I see nothing
see a whole lot of nothing there's a
whole lot of nothing just a me homie no
I hear did you drop your hat is that a
cake is that for me you mean oi all
right well anyway you have good day now
- OH - OH - - ah okay thanks for the
heads up thank you for that for the
alert
I don't think joy you're he's not it
that's not good look huh
it looks I feel good about looking oh
hello you are you doing me few shooing
[Music]
homie homie me no homie homie no oh oh
you mean no way I don't know where that
goddamn tape is I just don't know oh hi
oh that's not good that is the opposite
of good
okay well I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I'm looking I'm
not seeing though I don't see nothing oh
I don't see nothing
okay well there's bad oh oh hi hello
okay good ah that's not I'm not gonna
look at that mmm
okay all right then well I don't know
what to do oh boy okay that's gone now
all right
everything's fine apparently barely
everything's fine no not that not that
that's not what I wanted oh oh I win
yeah all right
let's carry on and why not yes hello
hello hello who's there okay I'm back
I'm gonna hurry this time mostly cuz
they're probably pretty active right now
now there's this big mess of parts and
stuff Dez appeared only after you first
arrived it appears to have the lamps in
it and for some reason it's full of
sharp teeth it looks like something
straight up a goddamn horror attraction
be honest though anyway once it's
assembled all of the parts it is going
to appear on your ceiling whoa I think
the best way to just keep it away is to
look at it when it's up there so make
sure to do that it dislikes being
watched
yeah okay oh yeah remember the plasma
source issue the old plasma source that
was used to create these messed up
ghosts is uh still around here if it's
there
play dead instantly look at the ceiling
and do absolutely nothing until you hear
it walk away that's pretty much the only
way to keep it out get it it doesn't
like other ghosts it's pretty
interesting it appears to want back
what's theirs well I'm gonna leave you
to it I and don't forget about
collecting the tape I can't find the
tapes I don't know where they are I
don't know what you want from me what
about what about my plasma good I don't
know why it wants my plasma huh is it
trying to sell me
I don't like any of this
yeah oh okay all right goodbye then I
don't know what you why am I supposed to
look at the ceiling so much I'm supposed
to play dad so it's like the same
mechanics for two different things but I
don't know which ones which well like it
like none of this okay hi
okay well that's not good mmm all right
that's weird okay
that was really weird that's not oh no
not that
no I didn't like that mmm girl please
don't take my goo
you took my goo didn't you you took my
goo oh yeah it was a ghost ghost ghost
ooh there there's a ghost
ectoplasmic goo all right that is
dormant abbess that is pretty good no
it's different it's definitely
differently a lot of these things the
the fascinating thing about it is they
they all come from a different
perspective of the same genre and yet
they all take some really unique
interesting ideas to it very good I like
it and by the way I didn't mention it
but all the links to the games are
available in the description down below
so if you want to play any of these you
can and should they are down there all
right next up jolly three
oh that's cool oh that's so cool
oh that's so cool that is really cool
it's not gonna line that is really cool
all right let's do this I'm ready I'm
ready
please scare me so good please scare me
yeah
and
damn oh good god
that was one hell of an intro not bad
not bad at all not bad
alright uh hello you hear me
no I do not alright so you should be
facing the main security office doesn't
over there Security office huh it's more
of a control room if you asked me hmm
okay you know what to do I don't get in
it's more facts and get out pretty
simple right
I don't know what I'm doing I don't know
I don't know Wow Wow
I don't know what I'm doing oh oh oh oh
oh I don't know in front of you but I
[ __ ] you excrete gas that fry
animatronic circuit activated phonics in
there oh now you know this little length
screeds gas there's enough supply for
them yeah if you run out of gas
you open up the camera and click the
little red icon you thought by corner
this is the maintenance screen yeah
there are a bunch of things you need to
keep track of yeah is gas supply once
the guests play is empty you could
refill it by clicking and holding the
refill button when you excrete gas you
will lose oxygen and your body will try
to intake much faster temporarily and
this will cause the oxygen supply to go
down for a bit but they'll automatically
fill itself
but these supplies may go broken and
you'll need to fix them to fix Gaston
click repair to automatically repair it
now you may notice these spinning hands
in the screen heat room in this building
has fans these fans may break from time
to time and you'll need to fix them to
fix up and click on the room but the
broken pane and click the button repair
fan
now the boom is you won't know what fan
is broken the facility used to have a
feature where you know what fan is
broken
but that means you have to go to every
camera until you're on the road with the
broken fan if you don't prepare them
your vision may go slowly dark
if these fans excrete oxygen from
outside but don't worry your vision
won't completely don't all right I think
that's it for some that actually I don't
know what we're doing
[Music]
oh hi hi hello hello who are you
about like that all right Wow
this is wonderful this is wound about
right that's not good Oh
oh boy
all right I don't know I don't know
panic I'm panicking
should I panic it's panic you're gonna
what to do
oh no there's another animatronic out I
don't know what that mean ha hello oh
you're on the way to me will and that
just a wonderful okay all right okay I
think I understand so when they get to
me when they get over to me I need to
use the gas to be able to disable them
so I need to know which ones coming
I said good girl sit up
I cannot gas it up I am trying to cash
it up i am i think that's bug I have no
idea
Wow Wow
what the hell what in the heck ahem
alright ok this is this is legitimately
cool this is super well made and I can
already see that there's a lot of depth
to it and there's a lot of reason to
look at the camera because you want to
know which fan is gonna be the one
that's gonna cause problems for you yeah
yeah that's true okay so both of these
guys are still there but I need to make
sure that my gas supply is always full
and ready to rock and then I need to
keep an eye on which fan is the one
that's lowest so that I can always stay
ahead of the curve
seems like this one this one this one
are already low alright hello hello okay
good good good oh my god dude this is
regard ambiguous okay I just wanna I may
not even be able to beat the first night
I may not be able to beat the first
night but I'm gonna try my damnedest to
be able to do that man this is just so
much stuff that you need to look at it's
just like camera after camera after
camera and there's so much stuff
happening in the background each camera
like what the hell is that [ __ ] I mean
these are obviously slightly different
animatronics than what we're used to and
got a lot of work has been put into this
no joke about that okay you're still
there you're still there my gas supply
is apparently good where do I even see
the time is there any location with
which to see the time because I don't
see that Oh 2:00 a.m. to a 100 that
sounds low or maybe it's the same speed
it's always been but seeing this minutes
tick by like that is fun
ah no now they're being really easy on
me all right well I guess I shouldn't
complain okay that one's almost dead it
looks like this one's about to fail
which is okay cuz I know which one no
not that one shoot that [ __ ] which one
which one which one oh no wait that's a
different thing oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
don't know what that is I can't breathe
okay I don't know eyes are broken fan oh
I saw a shadow some oh oh okay
that's what I needed
ah aha I want to mention there's
something very different about this game
compared to a lot of five nights at
freddys fan games like if you told me
that this one was made by Scott and I
didn't know it I think I'd lean towards
believing it because it has has this
sort of polished feel to it from the
sound to the music to all the different
variety of rooms to the tightness of the
mechanics to the the punchiness of the
actions it kind of does lead me to
believe that this is really high quality
stuff hey there's even Scott Caan's a
little symbol over there this is
legitimately high quality stuff that
should not be overlooked it is
legitimately quality I've said
legitimately like ten bajillion times
now but this is good this is really good
yeah and I imagine that this is an
animatronic that is gonna get up at some
point later on who knows when
who knows when but it's gonna happen
because there's three pathways that I
can see right here and they all lead
back to this room here so I just got to
find out how to be able to beat them and
then I'm gonna be happy that fans low
fan fan fan fan fan fan and that phase
real low no one might break it's all
good right I knew it I knew it
how did I know it that's different
sounds fair
okay Phil all right we're filled we're
full I'm very full oh hi buddy
yeah but in ski how you doing over there
hey one of those fans in the break I
know it right there goes which one there
it is there it is preparing I got it I
got it I got it I got it
okay I got it all right where are you
where are you buddy no don't wave of me
I don't like that okay god this is a
panic this is a kind of panic that I
haven't felt from a lot of these fan
games like like that's that's what I
really love about that the five nights
at Freddy's thing is like it gives you
this sense of panic like especially in
the beginning phase when you don't know
what you're doing gives you this sense
of dread where you're just totally at
loss for everything and anything
oh god all right but it's fun so far so
good
the fans are doing good I don't know
which one's gonna go down this one's
pretty low are you there you are you
gettin closer now when you get in here
you're not gonna be doing you're not
gonna get the best all right oh I don't
need to be so quick and [ __ ] about it
I really don't but hey I'm gonna try my
best [ __ ] fans gonna dive way when I
don't need it to not everything's fine
everything's fine everything's fine if
if they're hot okay I've got my gas I've
got my ass and you're gonna turn into
glass when you come in here I've got a
fist made of [ __ ] and I'm a blind [ __ ]
no [ __ ] wait wait now
[Music]
well good thing you didn't need my fist
made of pork all right okay
you back where you were supposed to be
no oh uh hi hello ah you didn't go back
as far as I thought you would agree you
don't want to know what I'm gonna do
with this fist if you come in here yeah
I know you can imagine all the ways that
this is going to impact your day-to-day
life but to be perfectly honest I don't
care about that right now this is time
right
[Music]
okay that doesn't sound good
oh I don't wanna go that way
just some clicking first okay why why am
I do that why am i do remember find
something and get out quickly stay for
too long and you're dead got it all
right why do I have to do this why can't
you be on scouting duty Dark One's here
try finding the password-protected safe
that I can hack into I'm trying my best
man I've got plungers you want plunger I
got tons of plunge I got lots of plunge
I'm trying to find a path try knocking
into one of those oh I see
[Music]
we have to hurry
I got this what I can't hack him safe
I need the safe port number and you know
anybody decided through you quickly
phone isn't you a program no I don't
want to do this easy it's welcome to the
grid mm-hmm if you use your mouse to
left-click on a box you'll create a
pathway right now if you get left
clicking on the box you'll change the
arrows direction okay I did it going
whoa aah I heard a thing that's prob mm
nope see don't don't like that don't
like that at all do that I'd really
don't want don't like that I have a bad
feeling about this
I knew something was wrong whoa oh my
god holy [ __ ] all right I'm gonna leave
this one here
holy [ __ ]
good God good God
right cool that was amazing like I'm not
I'm not being hyperbolic about it that
was legitimately amazing that was really
really well done that was astonishingly
well done that was stupidly well done
and I didn't even scratch the surface of
it that was so good
that was like five nights at or those
like sister location on steroids
that was ludicrously good man
I didn't think there was gonna be any of
these that I was tempted to play all the
way through but this is one of them
easily easily this is one that I would
love to play through my god that was so
good anyway I'm gonna leave this one
here and I'm gonna move on to the last
game in this series so this one is
called Bubba's diner now I don't know if
this game is more serious than the other
one I have no idea if this is a silly
one or a serious one but I'm gonna play
it nonetheless I don't know who Bubba is
Bubba's diner was originally created on
scratch as a way to occupy its creators
boredom we have the dining area the one
you're at right now the toilets on your
right to private party rooms right in
front of you back room to your left and
the basement over in the party hall feel
free to walk around to get to know the
location but beware time is passing you
have until 6 a.m. to conclude your task
tonight you have only one use the
printer while watching the location when
you're ready go to the room on your left
that's where you'll find your office huh
so it's kind of like pizzeria simulator
kind of thing going on here with Bubba
an ax can I have that can I have that I
need that for stuff and things I need it
to complement my fist which is very good
at one specific task all right well we
have here oh oh
windows not your office while you wait
for the printer watch the cameras in
test animatronics yes
test the program to go or this more
noise that is where there's more people
we let them walk around during some
parts of the day
anyway use the sound displays on the
screens to make noise and learn them
your room is noisy too if you feel
uncomfortable with the animatronics
staring at you
just getting away the different today
have a good night way tomorrow just kick
them away kisum what do i do - why
they're moving I don't like that French
some holster one dot jpg oh boy oh boy
press s to back ok alright ok I don't
like this I don't like this at all I
don't know what I'm doing but I feel
good about it I don't feel good about
this
oh hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's right outside my door I don't
know what do do it behind mm-hmm that's
not good
well alright well um something tells me
there's something behind me hmm
[Music]
I knew it I knew that anyway it didn't
seem like I was able to kick them back
or kiss them back so I don't know what
you wanted from me just get no way what
does that mean what do you mean get no
way that doesn't make any sense what do
you mean get no way that doesn't make
any sense it makes oh that makes that
get no just I don't don't get no way ah
mmm my well I'm dead all right
I don't know what you want me to do I
can't do nothing
[Music]
Oh what
what happened why I don't know what what
are you doing what I don't know what is
causing them to go away
ah why don't know what do you were see
that's the thing like this compared to
the last game it's funny this the
difficulty curve of the last one seemed
harder there was a lot more things to do
and yet this one I'm having more trouble
with and it's more frustrating the other
one I died a bunch but it was more
satisfying because it felt like it was
my fault here I just don't know what I'm
doing I think I'm maybe I'm starting to
get it man I don't know cuz I think if
they're by my door they got to go back
to the employee area right
or if they're by my door they got to go
back to the main lobby area if if I lure
them there but it's not working with
this guy see he's just coming in the
door no matter what I knew or me homie
no indeed oh me horny okay well that's a
difference so what does that mean I
don't even know if it's gonna be enough
for cuz I think I'm just gonna get
behind all right oh yeah there he is
he's right by my door god damn it okay
I'm so close come on I'm close I think I
don't know
no I'm [ __ ] no I'm not [ __ ]
I'm the opposite of Fabra knocked eyed
I'm not for knocked all right okay all
right okay what do I do
this task is done all right
[Music]
okay okay
all right I'm all done here
well so that explains that I guess I
think Oh confusing where am I now what
am i doing
why am I looking at this is this
supposed to signify B being at home do I
need to look at something
is this a loading screen I don't know
what it is is it a puzzle
[Music]
yeah no I'm not bored yes I'm a little
hungry yeah
[Music]
yeah okay all right I approve of the
promotional material I think I guess I'm
done now okay I'll carry on with my life
okay or the games gonna crash what is at
the end of it
why did you go to big screen curiosity I
spend half hour writing these facts okay
all right I don't know what that means
yeah well you may know the location that
means that you know where to go when
they ask you to for today you got two
tests the first one is to go to your
office again and print more stuff the
second one though isn't such a pleasant
task
you see we're having some problems with
the toilet over in the men's bathroom
yeah toilet of course you paid to be the
guy that does the kind of stuff that
nobody wants to do the handyman for
short move these arms repair yourself
and set some classic music you're about
to move crap out of the toilet all right
have a good night okay thank you thank
you so much I'm gonna go do that I guess
if I have to all right Oh danger why
would you say there was danger I have to
do the other task first why do I have to
do the other task that's stupid
okay I'll do the other task I guess all
right here we go can I get one of them
in the toilet toilet toilet go to the
toilet go to the toilet yes yes yes I've
boned you oh yeah
get rekt
[Music]
did I win what happened
Oh God my voice is almost completely
gone now what the hell happened I have
no idea what happened oh ah what what
Bubba's diner where fantasy and dreams
come to life
come do life they don't just come to
life they come do life ah okay that's
not a lot of money that's good good
amount of money but for a diner Oh
[Music]
yes no good that's no good it's no good
that's not good that is not good anyway
my voice is just about shot but thank
you so much for joining me for five five
nights at Freddy's fan games let me know
what you think of these games one of
them Jolley three had a lot more polish
than the others but it doesn't mean that
the others didn't have their own certain
charm and I hope you guys enjoyed me
compiling it in one video I certainly
have a lot of fun playing this and
contrasting them against each other and
I think the video as a whole is better
off than it would be if I was
individually playing these games now I
don't think I'm gonna play any of these
games to completion in a video series
unless may be jolly three but just
because that was so damn cool but let me
know anything down the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
it if you want to see more videos like
this big old compilation e videos let me
know down there as well thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye